not a platform for right-wing
commentators New York rightwing yeah
rightwing you're not we're we're a
platform for everyone uh and you know we
have sports leagues on there we got bkfc
we got UFC so I don't know where they
come up with that but they they find
their way you got to love New York
times's approach though they come from a
gentle approach and not non-judgment
loving on crap up you just with like go
for highly medicated so uh yeah so VC
was uh in our first public round prior
to public VC was part of that um with
naria capital and uh Peter teal uh and
he was one of the the larger the larger
investors and when we started so and and
that's with Peter the when they came in
yeah I think that was in May of 21 or
April of 21 has does he publicly talk
about it I don't hear him publicly
talking about it no I haven't heard do
you know why why he doesn't publicly
talk it's he's got money behind it he